this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
you look start the show with that yeah I
don't think you're realizing what you're
dealing with it
All Pro yeah we got to get you out to
the show man one of these I would love
it man when's the next one July 22nd in
San Diego oh damn it's in San Diego San
Diego I'm in town yeah because I was uh
when you had your show I was down in a
meeting with uh two casinos with Paula
and sequan and so I was going to try to
make your show but I think you're coming
on as I was leaving town oh dope I may
not know but
you look you look like a skinny actor
swear to God thank you that's the best
company I know it is you look like Jared
Leto oh my god dude you're talking to an
NFL he loves it he always I want to be
skinny we'll be at parties and he's like
this he goes I'm enormous he's he's
insecure about being huge and then I see
you well the thing is especially when
you get on the entertainment side a lot
of people you work with a smaller yeah
like when I remember when I retired I
was at NFL Network so I'm standing next
Willy McGinnis and all these other big
[__] people and then I started to do
like um stuff on E and [__] like that
and these guys are smart it's like me so
I'm looking like [__] a giant you
look like Shrek I'm looking like Shrek
on camera because I'm just so much
bigger than the rest of these guys look
at the Rock even when we came to
Hollywood because you know he was jacked
in the WWE he got so skinned I think
down to like 215 when he said where's
that tooth for that tooth fairy wow even
before that he got so thin and then he
said some agent told him do that and
he's like man she's got to be myself and
that's when he blew up yeah well what I
think is funny is it depends on like I
feel like you with very little effort
what's your what's your workout routine
I'm uh I still hit the weights you know
like four or five days a week but then
when I I'll leave and go to like extreme
Couture you know you're practicing MMA
as well yeah see look at the Rock real
quick look at the Rock there when he
first got there he lost he got off all
the sauce just didn't still have Simone
and all Samoans weighed 300 pounds but
they look like yeah thin dude he got he
got pretty he got pretty skinny now he's
like stupid what are you wearing right
now 268. well you played at 260 right at
260.
big freak I mean yeah no football that
great I know yeah I know you're right
because the charge team you're on
they're regarded I was watching on NFL
Network like during the season it was
the best teams ever yeah and your
chargers are like two or three on there
yeah it might have been number one
because his team was so stacked we were
so stacked yeah the dean Thomason or
like the defense Thomason was considered
I think it was uh who Gruden said he was
the best best running back he'd ever
seen in person do he I mean look I
played against AP I played again like
Clinton Portis I played uh I mean we
played against some guys what was it
like to hit Adrian Peterson
well he broke the damn Russian record
yes like in 2007. I've never seen
anybody run this angry before my life in
fact and he runs high and he runs high
and so you would think that somebody
that runs at high you can take a shot at
him but you never can get a clear shot
him so I asked him uh we would we were
doing um we're doing Tim Tebow's charity
event in Jacksonville
yeah we did it I did a bunch of times
yeah yeah and so we won the bus it is my
first time hanging out actually hanging
out with ap right I said after the fact
I said bro be honest
I said what what the [__] got into you
that day I said who said something
somebody said something to your mom or
your family who hurt you who hurt you I
said who pissed you off because I never
saw anybody run like this before my life
I'm angry might have been the alimony
has to pay to himself no that didn't
happen yet so I figured
I was like you know child support or
some [__] I was like somebody piss you
off right he said he said Sean to be
honest I just wanted to show LT up oh
damn he said he said LT was on the
opposite sideline I wanted to show LT up
why and I went back after the golf
tournament I seen LT
um at a charges event I said thanks dude
appreciate it he said what I said you
pissed you pissed AP off crazy bro we
played against Adrian Peterson the Big
12 Championship remember they hand the
ball at like the 10-yard line ran for 90
yards but but the guy was trying to
tackle him just bouncing off yeah I
shouldn't see him go I'm like hey we
don't have a chance to win this game B
I'm never playing that I was like oh
look at him you know Brandon Brandon
always when I see a guy like you like
what people like me come on and and
they'll be like well I was an athlete
and Brendan goes what are you talking
about you know be careful with the word
athlete now you know I play football I
ran a 4-6 and uh my friend goes I ran a
4-6 in uh High School Brandon goes no
you didn't no you didn't no I did he
goes look at me you didn't right well I
mean it was a stopwatch because let's
get
serious him I go you're [__] huge you
know people but but then I see you stand
next to him and I go okay well there are
all these levels to this game and that's
NFL bro have you ever seen Eddie George
like crazy it's he's like him yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly it's no he's not
taller
dude yeah you're a legit 64. no I'm
telling you he's every bit of six four
they might have him six three on there
he couldn't be more handsome by the way
dude
again he was he still looked good yeah
but back then you know what else looks
good who I just saw who looks damn good
yeah everybody is jacked uh Mr Shannon
sharp oh yeah yeah Shannon Shannon still
hits it though yeah he still hit him
pretty hard oh what are you are you you
watch your diet really carefully you're
vain you're good oh good this way I got
I got my days the thing is I'm not a big
eater though you know so if I yeah I eat
like three times Max sometimes twice a
day
right yeah so if I if I do [__] or
like eat some like I eat pizza last
night right yeah but then again I will
eat like twice a day yeah so actually in
my size I should be like lots of great
genetics though yeah because there's a
freak so he's a freak out Maryland and
then the dude that fall in Vernon Davis
Arizona
the Broncos you son of a [__] and then
49ers yes so Vernon so Vernon is Vernon
Davis and Antonio commodity the two the
freakish athletes I played with really
yeah
he's got 13 kids I don't know if you
know that but I think 12 years you know
that yeah you know he's got 13 kids yeah
eight baby moms but yeah but he was
begging the judge he was like look I
can't but he's a free conquer him
already he's a freak yeah yeah he's six
three 220 pound corner you know corner
with that kind of
so I used to have to cut like me and
Vernon would go at it and fight every
day in practice so when he got there he
only played two years of high school
football so he wasn't that good he was
just an athlete yeah so I used to take
him one-on-one password just trying to
block him I would throw his ass all
around and just do everything to him
right the following year he came back
and he was [__] so strong
like his whole everything his body just
changed he got strong he started
understanding football and then so I had
all the records because they got this
thing in Maryland where they where
you're the iron turd right so I had a my
max bench at the time I think it was
like 45 or 490 or some [__] out of 690
Squad had a 375 power handling you know
crazy numbers and so he got up there he
[__] he took all my [__] off the wall
my vertical the only thing the only
thing I kept was my vertical was like 41
and a half you got a vertical of 41.
dang freak but I also but uh tell me if
this is true I heard this is during the
draft I always watch the draft and
they're saying one of the biggest kind
of like
stories especially your draft year is
the Cowboys were going to take you early
Cowboys were supposed to pick him so so
before the draft you go out and you meet
with the teams that want you right this
this so I met with four teams before the
draft I'll fly you out you meet with all
the the front office right right so if
you're if you're somewhere like the top
15 20 pick they'll have you to come out
so I came out to Dallas and I sat down
with Jerry
20 guys are downstairs 20 of the guys
are looking at the first round they flew
us all in and so they sent somebody
downstairs to grab me and they said hey
you know Jerry Jones and Bill Parcells
want to see you upstairs big names so at
the first at first I'm thinking I'm like
[__] what did I do right right football
royalty yeah so I'm like oh [__] what
did I do you know somebody you know I
pissed somebody off right so they called
me upstairs we're sitting in the off in
the office half this size
Bill Parcells is behind his desk and
Jerry Jones is sitting on the table on
the table next next to us and uh they
said look we got the number 11 pick we
don't think that you're going to be
there by 11 we go somewhere in the top
five top seven right but if you are
we're gonna draft you Bill Parcell said
this to me and this is what like
I don't want to come here right he said
as soon as you come in we're going to
work the [__] out of here but he was
known that's that's him all defense I've
actually read a lot about Bill Parcells
because winning to him was like if he
lost his wife like his wife was like I
can't she could never be around him
because it he took it so seriously he he
[__] when he said that and you know
first of all I'm 20 years old right so
when I got drafted I was the youngest at
the time ever and I'm sitting there
you're looking at two of the most
prominent figures in in football royalty
yeah and I'm sitting there I'm like I'm
in a room with [__] Jerry Jones and
Bill Parcells and they got this teeny
tiny you could feel like the damn you
could feel it in a room this attention
yeah and I'm like [__] I don't know what
to do and they said we want you to 11
pick but we don't think you're going to
be here Bill Parcell said yeah when we
get you soon the first day you get here
we're going to work the [__] out of your
ass and I was like I was like my head
I don't want to come here and then but
we made it just as worse is that the
charges had the next pick which was
Marty schottenheim and Marty wasn't no
no punk either yes you know Marty ain't
played it Marty ain't played that [__]
why do you think Schottenheimer when he
would get people to the playoffs or he'd
get you right there right get over the
hump he couldn't get over the hump and a
lot of people thought maybe it was
because he couldn't improvise on the
spot he couldn't like change like he'd
see something he'd be like if it wasn't
planned beforehand and he had to do it
by the seat of his pants he would almost
like pants he did with the Chiefs did
with the charges and you guys had the
most Talent well the thing is with
Marty's attitude I'll tell you the truth
for one we had to go through Peyton
Manning and Tom Brady to get to Ben
Roethlisberger by the way right by the
way but Prime
you actually excused everything yeah so
so you you got to get there first and
then what happens is to get there see
what made the Patriots so good is they
made all these adjustments all the time
all they they adjusted every so most
teams that just have time to come out a
new game plan they adjusted on the spot
that's right and so with Marty Marty had
his attitude like we're going to run the
ball we're going to do the [__] we want
to do and they got to stop it and that
that kind of bit Us in the ass a little
bit because I remember when you're
playing against somebody as good as the
patriots who are always making these
adjustments and you're not adjusting
that's been behind that's
I don't know a lot about football but I
remember seeing that in real time I
remember I know exactly the game you're
talking about yeah I was like
something's going on to be honest we
were so stacked that year we won 14-2
nobody should have beat us no that's a
and that was the NFL networker was
saying as far as on paper the most
talented team of all time assistant yeah
because we think about it Antonio Gates
in his prime yep stupid teams
Philip Rivers you have Vincent Jackson
that wide receiver by the way Colorado I
Love Philip Rivers and he had the
weirdest throwing thing it looked like
he would throw from here it looked like
but you know why why so when he was a
kid his dad was a coach and so he used
to throw a bigger football than you know
than he was so he was in his hand the
ball was too big so he started to push
the ball out that became his point
interesting you ever see him he was like
he was a waiter and he throws he pushes
I always loved that [__] because
he looked like a guy who would fight you
right now he's feisty am I right I don't
feel so he went he went to NC State and
I went to Maryland and then back when
they were in ACC
and I hated Phil so much because on when
you're watching football film you don't
get the commentaries view you it's
silent yeah and you get the coaching
field you get this uh the side angle and
then the uh back from the back right
yeah the long angle and so
you would see Philip all the time
on the to players even after he got hit
or sorry he was talking the whole time
and you like man I can't wait to play
this I'm gonna [__] him up right because
he just talked so much yeah yeah and
then we I hit him his last year because
he never beat me when he was at NCC he
lost all three years right and so
I hit him at the end of the game back in
the end zone and I get up and I push off
of his chest he goes and grabs my ankles
and get to he's starting to twist it he
grabbed I pushed off of him he grabbed
my ankle and so I was like what the f I
got up you know you don't expect that
from recording now do he got a small
quarterback not a small quarterback we
got a picture one of the one of the most
iconic pictures ever me and him I got my
visor on we're in the back of the end
zone and we're we're this close and
we're about to scrap and in my head I'm
like this [__] is crazy
I said I went from hate them to like
respect that's right and then right and
then when I got drafted and went there
this is the second or third year I
forgot what year it was when I came
there
you got around him he's the most
competitive player I've ever been around
played with in my life Jordan style yeah
yeah because he because of players like
that he would it would it didn't stop on
the field he would challenge you in a
locker room he will challenge you and
get in in a card game exhausted he would
challenge you you'll be you'll be
benching this [__] right and said we're
playing uh Seattle we're playing the
Seahawks and I'm on a bench and I got
you know 160s one
he said you know you got Walter Jones
this week those 160s like he didn't
curse right so he everything he says
right there
yeah ah and so me and him is that we're
in the background he by the way he's got
his hands full like he's tough but he's
got his hands full with him I'm going to
destroy him yeah he doesn't care that's
the thing
yeah and uh from that day man I you know
and just meeting him and be around him
and he was a guy that normally in the
NFL you got the linebackers from the
linebackers the d-line with the d-line
o-line Phillip will come in the d-line
table linebacker table and sit with us
and talk [__] to everybody right talk
[__] to you guys and just go back and
forth he was just that man and he was
the most competitive player that uh ever
played with can we take
listen I'll tell you it's a good time
tonight my Denver Nuggets are gonna win
the NBA Finals they've never even been
to the finals we're going to close out
game five My Brother Jay Sharkey's doll
smile is going to the game you son of a
[__] he's gone if you want to watch my
Nuggets win and make Bank do it with the
official sports betting partner the NBA
we talk about DraftKings new customers
can make plays a five dollar bet and
score 200 in bonus bets instantly plus
all customers can take a shot of bigger
payout with the DraftKings stepped up
same game parlays download DraftKings
sports book app right now use code
fighter new customers can place a five
dollar bet and score 200 in bonus bets
instantly let's go fighter only at
DraftKings sports book
download it now DraftKings promo code
fighter gambling problem called 100
Gambler Massachusetts call 800-327 5050
or visit gambling help
ma.org and New York call 8778 Hope NY or
text Hope NY 467-369 in Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort 21-0 page varies by
jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
reply see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details in space specific responsibility
gambling resources bonus bonus bets
expire seven days after uh issuance
opt-in and 10 plus legal required for
100 boost 100 boost eligibility wagering
deposit restrictions apply terms at
Sportsbook dot draftkings.com basketball
terms DraftKings promo code fighter go
nuggets
macadamias are lower in net carbs than
most popular nuts they have the best fat
profile all right they're like avocados
on steroids they have they have more
monosaturated fat than Olive Oil okay
they're rich in omega-7 fatty acids
apparently that can help you with
natural collagen production glucose
metabolism reducing inflation but who
cares
they're delicious they're delicious
white chocolate ones on the desk right
now Sean Merriman took two packages of
these we can't contain these nuts
in my mouth I got them chocolate right
now vanilla cover I just I can't the
package oh the little go-to's and you
got the bars oh my God I love them and
listen people think they're only for the
rich not anymore because our friends at
House of macadamias they have over 90
Farms so they make it more immersive
yeah dude it's not farming dude they're
creamy nut Butters dude get out here the
cold pressed extra virgin macadamia oil
what are we doing here no added sugar no
artificial ingredients just nuts
covering delicious stuff for your
discount give them a discount okay even
though we never run a discount the code
I'm going to tell you right now the code
you want me to give it code right now is
tfak I'm gonna say that okay number two
nuts in your mouth you want buttery
macadamia nuts Brennan oh you feel like
Santa Claus you feeling generous go
ahead I'm the nutmaster Macadamia snack
bars you get a free box one of each
flavor when you visit
houseamacademias.com
tfak 20 off your entire order whatever
you want the raspberry covered vanilla
chocolate macadamias the chocolate
covered the bars the regular nuts for
your mouth we got it all House of
macadamias.com tfak twin soft plus you
get a free box of the snack bars all the
flavors enjoy you nutty [__]
hopefully when we were driving back from
San Diego we're talking about your team
and uh we were talking about best tight
ends of all time just so happens the
next day uh Skip Bayless Shin sharper R
unit Shan sharp says when you look at
statistics and winning it's Gronkowski's
the best then I'm probably second and
then you have Kelsey there and then uh
uh Skip Bayless and Chan sharp okay and
Skip Bayless goes well where would you
put Antonio Gates and Shannon sharp goes
he's not in the top five not even the
top ten because he can't block everybody
on that list can block Antonio Gates and
he said the reason they didn't win the
Super Bowl is because he was a liability
he couldn't block with [__] because you
played basketball well Shannon for one
they don't they always had a
disagreement like their whole time
playing the same conference yeah play
the same conference to me personally I'm
not saying this uh because I played with
him you know Gates is in the top three
for sure right even though he can't
block even though well he the thing is
with him and how we were built in the
first place you're not asking him to
block no he's right
Difference Maker yeah if you threw the
ball to Antonio Gates he was catching
the ball and he was so much bigger than
everybody else he but you if you look at
him and if you watch him run his route
because he played basketball when he get
in and out of his Cuts it's almost like
he was dribbling yes the ball in his
first step out of that cut you can do
nothing about it nothing really even if
you knew what he was doing he would give
you just enough shake to get open how
long have you been into M A how long
you've been training MMS uh 2006. is
that long yeah long so Jiu Jitsu boxing
yeah so I started so I met you you were
starting to do it yeah yeah so I I grew
up in Prince George's County Maryland
Washington that DMV area right so we had
Championship boxes my I had uncles that
were professional boxers so we grew up
just naturally Boxing Around
neighborhood the cookouts and if we had
a problem in the cookout family cookout
the gloves are coming out wow right that
was it and so I grew up boxing and
everybody in your family you get your
athleticism both sides yeah yeah my dad
ran tracking my mom place you had some
beasts in that in that family tree
something yeah okay yeah and so I grew
up boxing and then so one day I'm with
Jay Glazer and we're in the gym and I'm
boxing I'm sparring to God he noticed I
can I can box a little bit so he said
man I think you should try out MMA and I
think MMA will help you with your
football hand you know using your hands
being outside linebacking pass for us so
I said [__] if it'll help me in football
I'll try it out so he's text me the
address the next day I show up just
right here off of labret it's when uh
Randy Couture had his gym oh extreme
coutures out there all right he knows
here right off the bridge uh Legends
Legends and so I walk in the gym and
then uh Jay glazes on my left Randy
Couture is on my right and so I'm
looking at Jay like I'm not about to
fight Randy Couture today you [__]
crazy like you know I don't I don't know
what it's my first day yeah I'm like I
don't know what he's setting up I'm like
I'm not fighting Randy Couture today I'm
you know like hell no I'm ready by the
way was was still fighting is that still
active yeah and so he said no no you're
going to pumble you're going to do some
stuff you're going to show you like just
work and this is when I knew that MMA
was different because at the time I'm
260 plus I'm probably 40 50 pounds
heavier than Randy stronger than faster
than but we were probably he was [__]
throwing me around yeah he's not tearing
peep out of you he was throwing me
around and I couldn't unders I couldn't
get it was so I was so frustrated on how
he was just being able to do these
things and I couldn't do anything about
it and so every day I started to work
with Randy and then um there was some
other former there were some other
athletes transitioned over like I had um
Clay Matthews will pop in there some
days
um from the Rams yeah
I'm sorry but but all of it like that
hand fighting is all good because people
don't realize like o-line d-line outside
linebackers when they're rushing it's
all hand fighting right so all the
movements it's so good right a lot of
guys incorporating it and so it's Crosby
who's yes probably number one number two
Russia in the NFL Big Time guy wow MMA
big time I told I sold Max the other day
um I was was talking to him at the
Fanatics event the Super Bowl and when I
was I said dude we should go because we
we're supposed to go train you know at a
extreme Couture in Vegas and I said dude
one of these days man like you got to
consider like looking at you know he's
made a lot of money he's just got a new
contract so he's not gonna actually
fight but guys like him are the ones
that could transition over and actually
have some success in MMA let me ask you
this show because there's been when you
look at the successful guys who played
football whenever the UFC used to have
Brock Lesnar uh Metrion myself and then
Greg Hardy yeah I think the biggest one
is Greg Hardy because he had the best
NFL career out of all of us right I had
a cappuccino with Buffalo Bills Mitchell
Mitchell played six years was it really
like a starter he got some play Brock
Lesnar just went to training camp so me
and Brock or similar training camp Greg
Hardy was all pro yeah I think all pro
one year uh he was uh yeah all pro yeah
stud you know on this on the pro ball
it's just it's such a hard transition
because if you've seen lately Greg Hardy
like knocked I think three four numbers
he started off hot but you get to a
certain level where if you're not doing
it a lot there's not enough hours in the
day to make it make up for it because
then you get with those Vats and they
they've seen well it'd be athletic I
would love to see a guy of his
athleticism who started really young
well so the money's not into it so when
I when I just saw mirman's Dad you're
not gonna be like hey what do you think
of the UFC or how about you get
guaranteed the money signing bonus and
play [__] so so whenever when I
retired
um and I was I was still active actually
I picked up on my training more and I
was talking to Bellator so with Scott
Coker and the whole crew and they were
so you got good enough at that point oh
yeah yeah yeah so we we were um we were
putting together a uh a deal and they
never came before with the money I was
looking for because they didn't see it
at the time right and so now and that
was it was like a half million bucks
right because I really just wanted to
fight and I said I was telling got
everybody on the team I said dude I can
you a half a million bucks that should
be nothing for you guys because you get
somebody else another former athlete and
I think they call them like freak shows
or circus fights or whatever it is yeah
give me give me a guy in the uh in the
WWE a former WWE or former athlete and
let's [__] scrap and make this a big
deal right and they just never came to
the table with the money I was looking
for and that was it but at the time I
was going to going to do it it was just
a timing of it like now now you get paid
now you can get paid yeah but also you
can get paid for Fighters right pay for
it at your level in the NFL or paid at
Greg Hardy's level when he was you know
All Pro or these other boys it's tough
man yeah cause they look at they go what
right this is chump change and I get a
train for this [__] and at the time
I was so I was at NFL Network
um yeah I was making six figures there
and I just was working with the WWE
right because the WWE had launched their
uh the network and so I was doing stuff
I hosted WrestleMania the ones that were
New Orleans I would did Monday night
raws and smackdowns I was working with
them on the side but I also was training
down Performance Center
and so what happened was we were I was
going to spend half the time doing my
show NFL Network and I was going to
spend another half down there
and then a fight came up so I said look
in order for me to stop doing anything
I'm doing it has to be a certain amount
of money in order for me to consider it
and they just never really came back to
the table is it true you think that NFL
players play with 100 pain everybody on
that team is paying in pain in some way
yeah 100 and the fact is when you the
first day of training camp hey man look
the first day of training camp you have
a finger a wrist a back a hair look at
your broken fingers yeah dummy I broke
this [__] so many times I just left I
let it go right it's like Ronnie Lott
cut it off yeah yeah yeah and so uh it's
it's a brutal sport but the difference
is it's a different kind of um
you know when you eat if you got some
injuries in football you can't play
football as much anymore right like
mattrion right he was a subpar Athlete
on the field like he was a decent
athlete but an Amma side freak freak
he's a freak yeah there's no doubt that
the athletic pool in the NBA the and and
even even I would even argue MLB I mean
any of these Major League where all the
money is there the freaks like you go
there it would just make sense I mean
you got to think that some of the
biggest if the money was there back then
you got some of these guys linebackers
and strong savings from Alabama and Ohio
State I would say yoel Romero is a is it
is a guy who's yes
I've seen around Sprints yeah it's just
it's also a different skill set that's
why I don't like it I don't like that
different I don't like that you want to
see a silver vertical jump compared to
him
there are some exceptions there's not
there's this ain't even close the best
athlete of all time in the UFC is who
just I would say I would say uh
pure athleticism you're all Romero
probably was never a champion but most
people would say GSP I would say GSP
just he's always labeled the yeah great
athlete Great Gate gamer great hello
look at GSP even now [__] handstands
is crazy yeah like yeah yeah we have
four nine in the 40. uh Jon Jones the
goat right the goat 100 you're at a 5-1
in the 40 brother yeah he's not his
brother Nate Diaz what do you think they
run in the 40. well again this is where
we get into fighting is just different
it's something there's something but I
hate when people dude if you could get
you know Jon Jones NFL oh he wouldn't
make it he wouldn't get through high
school football yeah it's a different
set of skills yes wrestling well I bet
Michael Phelps would be a phenomenal
title excuse me the guy that swims right
so that's what you say it
Romero though would be an example of a
world champion wrestler I think being a
high-level wrestler has nothing to do
with football athleticism no but but you
have to be crazy athletic to be a world
champion those guys aren't a they
couldn't sniff the NFL
you know what's crazy so the reason why
you know this big you could you could
say that and the reason why I know what
he's talking about is because I got a
chance to be and train with some of the
best guys in MMA right even in sparring
and stuff like I've been in there with
some of the best to do it and so I can
hang with anybody on the athletic front
but you know like sometimes I'll tussle
around with Tito's like it's just
different level man it's a different
skill I mean you mean he's just got he's
got more tricks yeah but you know
standing up you know I can cause a
problem for anybody yes but you got you
got somebody like him or somebody uh
even when I came in so Tyrone Whitley
was just coming on in the mid-2000s and
I was training with him and that at the
time he was terrible standing up awful
yeah when he first started and I'm
looking at him and I'm like this dude
gonna fight MMA and boy and I see him
take somebody to the ground and do [__]
to him and I ask you okay this is
different you know yeah because he's
just a different skill set no I think I
do think that if you take if you like
the guy who won the gold medal he's 21
years old in heavyweight division in
wrestling that guy's a crazy athlete if
you if you took him from an early age
and he he's he's got the kind of
athleticism I think to be anything you
know it just depends but I don't think
so I don't think it works why they've
done it it's just it's a different
because I think wrestling requires so
much you know flexibility strength and
football doesn't power I think wrestling
just as much as anything anything no
well if they're so like like Ray if you
look at the wrestlers who wrestled in
college or high school and then they
played in NFL like Ray Lewis I think
Brian they're like some of these some of
these guys were great wrestlers and then
it transitioned into the field right
like they it were tackling everything
else
there's very few things you can do in
MMA that's going to transition into on
the football field yeah it's gonna take
a lot like but here's the thing there's
a heavy there was a wrestler he was a
world uh National Champion wrestler
think out of
um
yeah I forget where he's out of maybe
Minnesota I forget but the he did he
didn't play it down a football but he
was like six eight he beat Brock Lesnar
twice the Patriots drafted him he became
one of the best tackles to ever do yes
well the thing is football my thing is
it depends on the position right so if
you're a wide receiver you're a great
athlete but the what it requires of you
which is to run routes catch balls and
keep running you could make the argument
that that skill set isn't as diverse as
for example uh MMA right so so learning
how to kick punch wrestle all those
things is not as diverse as these shoes
yeah because you got a thing too also in
that position wide receiver they're
doing everything for it to me the most
athletic position on the field what is
cornerback and then the guy who can rush
to pass because you're required to do a
whole lot more if you're a cornerback
you gotta you're running backwards of
the guy to maybe run a four three or
four and knows where he's going he knows
where he's going but you could say that
speed right you could say he's got a
crazy explosive speed and there that's a
specific Lane and you and you think hold
on you think there's wrestler that is
born in America that could play
cornerback in the NFL well I don't know
no I'll answer that no but but but but I
think there are very athletic people in
the wrestling game but but it's a
different sport and it may be that the
really athletic guys who are very fast
and Powerful go into football because
that's where the money is of course they
do they're crazy athletes in wrestling
but I I I I think that it's a really
interesting thing because I actually
think the hardest position in sports is
cornerback I mean quarterback
quarterback is to me it's more of a
mental it's well like Tom Brady is
probably the worst Athlete on the field
right so that's what I'm saying though
but it's such a as far as athletic it'd
be corn to his point linebacker uh
outside linebacker rush like yeah
rush you give me you give me a young
Khalil Mack right Savage you could be a
young Khalil Mack 15 years ago and you
give me a chance to train him MMA
zero to from the day from yeah like if
you took Sean and you he was 15 years
old and you're like you're a train can
you imagine what he I mean is there any
doubt he'd probably be he'd be you know
who's gonna [__] hang with a guy like
that at that level but no but if you
have a and you have a kid let's say
let's see you went to University of
Buffalo by the way but let's say your
kid was really an athletic bee right are
you gonna say Hey Now You're gonna fight
no you're going to play or football
football look at him there's no
comparison
just for the biggest freaks in the world
are in the NFL what's going so what's
going on I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
take the transition I'm gonna tell you
what's going on in the transition from
these guys so you got as you say you
played a little bit in NFL and a lot of
these guys not gonna have a eight nine
ten plus year career you're going to get
your linebacker from Alabama Florida
State or your strong safety it only
played three or four years in the NFL
just gonna transition MMA I'm talking to
four guys right now to have them come
over the lights out extreme fight the
only reason why they didn't sign yet
because they were with the XFL and they
got called up oh they got called up but
they were ready to sign with lights out
extreme Fighting well the guy who fought
on Saturday night
yeah yeah UFC 289 uh Anders Eric Anders
who's the linebacker Alabama he's a line
back to Alabama
and mind you though so
the reason why Greg Hardy didn't have
the long like he had a stem he he has he
was fighting some championships he's so
late to the game he was late to the game
the older he's older late to the game
but the fact that you can have a long
career in football and make that
transition and be able to fight but I
forgot who he 44 the long he had five
rounds of a guy who actually was up for
a belt at one point look Herschel Walker
had 50. looks pretty damn good yeah but
the other point look at Brock Lesnar
yeah didn't sniff the NFL yeah that's
also above it because again football is
those intangible skills that take a long
time to develop so he was new like I
don't think he played in college right
he played in high school ooh Brock
Lesnar he's a wrestler he's a wrestler
yeah so you know he's playing against
guys and there's just those details that
make all this but I'm saying he's
athletic couldn't sniff the NFL goes to
UFC champion in three fights yes but you
know the idea is if Brock had started
football playing football in college
could he have been in the NFL probably
you know
um it's hard to say probably why there's
so many Brock Lesnar's he's not a freak
in the NFL not even close you don't
think he's a freaking animal no you got
it you gotta be I'm telling you Butler
dude look at it you know his dime a does
it you know who almost the same size and
he's a world champion UFC yes and NFL
couldn't sniff he he's like he got a
[__] Jersey there's there's a hundred
block lenses in Camp right now that will
be working at Starbucks tomorrow and the
fact he was 69.
you know the guy you know the guys that
got the shitty numbers you like that
yeah yeah
I saw him in the preseason wearing 60s I
was like yeah
that's so crazy because there are a lot
of Brock lesnars aren't there there are
a lot of guys like that who are just as
strong everywhere
what's that now get it get a oh yo Aaron
Donald right he's a little shorter or
whatnot but if Aaron Donald had another
entry to on him he's about 297 pounds
freak freak I don't know how he's that
heavy
I can short because he's six feet tall
it's so weird number one in the NFL yeah
what the [__] is going on with that guy
if you took him and yeah
when you leave Sean do you get a little
competitive because you're not not now
you're not hearing a peep out of him
when you were playing though not now but
you're not when you were playing I'm
just saying when you're playing and he
starts punking you you're not backing
down but he's a he's on defense no I
know but I just if you try to stop it
but I know but no no so to answer your
question real quick Sean was as dominant
as he was for about three years yeah
just as dominant yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah what happened is the further
you get away from the game like
that's why I could never coach or be
around the game because my mentality was
still to be a player right to challenge
everybody but every couple years you get
away from the shooting like okay you
kind of let that go but the problem is
that I'm still training with a lot of
these guys for a long time with MMA oh
I'm looking at your body you've not let
it go don't act like you're like um no
mentally you're amazing mentally not
physically do you have kids yeah I got a
son does he play football yeah plays
quarterback it's tough right yeah like
my kids in football now he's like yeah
okay but you know It's just tough not
and the coaching like hey could you just
maybe switch some [__] up you know what
I'm saying yeah it's like what are you
doing does your son have your
athleticism he does he does Trump he
doesn't have he doesn't have my like
attitude like I want when I played I
wanted to hit every [__] body right I
didn't care about the football I didn't
care about anything that's everything I
wanted to hit and just kill everything
right he has a more of like a athletic
you know approach to a freakish athlete
plays quarterback yeah freakish athlete
he doesn't drive you nuts he doesn't
have like that like it drives me and my
son's seven so maybe it'll come but I
was up obsessed it was all I thought
about it hey dude don't you want to like
throw the football around him he's like
no I want to play you know whatever it's
a different time because two you know
you played a you whether you play one
year or ten years you got an opportunity
to play this you know the mentality yes
and so which would you try to stay away
from first of all you're showing my name
is kid on the football so I try to take
the back seat to everything even even
his coaches when I come to the games and
[__] they want me to they want me to be
more involved than I do like the last
thing I want to do is put more pressure
13. yeah it's also like you be careful
what you ask for right because you know
what they said they've done a lot of
studies on on parents that burn their
kids out uh build resentment of their
kids or parents who are really good so
much of what you can do as a parent is
just say I love watching you play right
and we'll let them decide yeah I tell my
son like especially guys like you who
have especially shot like a legend like
it's that's a huge treat for him I just
tell my son have fun in the back of my
God that's me that's me have fun have
fun because they lost basketball he
missed two free throws and we in the car
and he's just fine I'm like
be a cool man it's a critical moment
this little dude's life I just turned
out I went I just turned out all song
did you have fun you're gonna see you're
doing it for you guys yeah you expect
it's all about fun yeah my kid's not
gonna be a D1 athlete so it's fine for
me I'm like we're having fun it's a good
time because we know behind the curtain
like I'm like oh dude you you need to
have that killer mentality yeah that's
what I need out of you dude well as a as
a ghetto I will say this as they get
older because when they're younger they
don't understand what they can do yet
correct right they don't get it so my
but my son is getting to the point where
he know he's strong you know he's fast
he knows he's so now he's starting to do
it he's an outlier like I feel like once
they know they have a special skill set
yeah that's why I'm like okay and I'm
getting attention doing this okay I'm
gonna do it yeah like did you see that
uh they call him baby Gronk have you
seen this baby yeah I've seen it no so
this kid his dad's like he's the best
whatever nine ten-year-old on the planet
has offers from University of Arizona
which I don't think really does so he's
reached out to our boys at busting with
the Bros right busting with the boys
he's trying to get him all this
attention so this look this little kid
you know and I have a buddy who uh his
son's on his team that's Mom
that's the most famous person in college
sports she's the highest nil deal she's
a gymnast for LSU right not his mom dude
she's she's uh get younger she's uh
perfect I want to get in Time Machine
yeah and go back as an athlete and marry
yep not about her though so get the girl
off screen otherwise we're not gonna get
through this chin sorry so little grunts
his dad is like he's like he's only rice
and uh salmon
in the NFL oh it's a disaster so we I
talked to him sometime on uh on IG and I
talk like that and I talk to him oh
you've talked to him yeah isn't that
crazy yeah no it's or is he cool he's
cool but I think that the the exposure
he's getting right now no matter what
whether he goes and plays or not it's
fine with them you get what I'm saying
like he like they just wrote they had a
big article a couple New York Times yeah
Paige I posted was like this can't end
well yeah like this kid's gonna end up
hating football also he looks like such
an [__] yeah right he's probably not
he's seven he just looks like an [__]
how old is he big seven eight maybe he's
only seven or eight maybe so his
highlights I mean he's Balling on these
he's too young to be with all this
energy let's just let him if it feels
like his death the reason his dad's
getting so much hate because it's like
that it feels like the dad's pushing the
question right yeah I think after 10 you
can call him [__] yeah I think that's
the age but anyway he's here he's not um
you know I talked I talked to him and I
talk to his dad and they reach out to
you for what reason we well we follow
each other and I saw him follow me he
shot me a DM and said he was a fan and
stuff like that and I kind of responded
back but we've been communicating since
and I just think that the the attention
that they're getting now they're taking
advantage of whether he goes or not when
you were 10 to make money did they at 10
years old did they know you were
something special
um it was like my
freshman like yeah going into my
freshman 18 years old yeah 13 14. where
you were you were just bigger and
stronger no so when I so when I got my
my nickname lights out right I got that
when I was 16.
but I started to just get sides and
stuff with me I always had mentality but
I didn't have the size and so like my
freshman sophomore year I started
putting on a little size of lifting
weights and I still kept my speed and
everything else so that's why I started
blowing people up that's when I got the
nickname so that's when the chatter of
like at my first ESPN like they now the
high school rankings came out I was like
top 50 top 20 25 whatever it was in the
country and um
the my first uh article of the first
reporter came up to me they said you
know I was ranked they said hey man why
did you you know why did you play
football why do you why how you got
you're passionate you go out you do a I
said to be honest man I can do anything
I want to anybody not go to jail
I didn't have any media training right
so I didn't so reports like yeah that's
absolutely yeah okay have a good day
that's great answer that's what he did
that's a great answer so I you know I
got now but you know what's great about
that answer it was kind of true like as
far as you were concerned you were just
like a warrior that needed today's world
today's world they take him to jail yeah
right he falls to the fourth round right
but like you know your character issues
yeah all this other [__] right and so
but I but it was it was like uh it was
genuine because that's how I felt about
the game I said that I could literally
do anything first of all you back then
when you knocked somebody out had a big
hit you get applaud it for it right now
it's a CTE concussion
suspended but then when you did it like
every time I knock somebody Seattle I
had a big hit I looked over to my
coaches my coaches like yeah you got a
sticker on your home right yeah
literally it's thicker and so they do
that so you get applaud it for it so I
literally started to play the game
because
I could do anything I want to you and
not go to jail that was my mentality and
I but I didn't think twice to say that
because the guy they had little tape
recorders back then they said oh you're
passionately this why do you play I said
I could do anything I want everybody to
not go to jail I'm 16 years old right
and they he did that he's all um excuse
me
I said uh yeah I could I can do anything
I want to you and not go to jail with a
smile on my face I was so happy about it
right and you thought it was all great I
thought it was great
answer I was like it was great that's a
good answer you know but I'm for sure
when he when he stopped that tape
recorder like 20 seconds later I'm sure
he walked off and said this guy's going
to jail one day
God for football because maybe true
right yeah or you would have been a
fighter oh Dad yeah what about CT man
you don't you obviously don't suffer
from any it looks like you don't have
any energy injuries or anything and and
you know I think it's just probably
genetic it's a question of all kinds I'm
saying this about CT before you go in on
it there was uh
there's an article on oh uh it was BJ
Penn
um he put uh how many people do you know
CT how many people do you know that
fought and you see how many you know
that actually have CTE goes it's fake
like the disease yeah uh
I'm not saying it's fake but I am saying
is it is the exception when we see the
outliers Junior Seau yeah you see you
know some of these guys that have really
bad CT and it's not a reason that
parents shouldn't let their kid play
football how many people do you know
that played football since you were a
kid till now that are completely fine
the majority yeah the majority but that
movie concussion came out right now it
becomes this big spectacle it doesn't
mean it doesn't mean that that CT
doesn't exist like you said it's like
it's a it's a thing but I think if you
took the mean aggregate if you took like
the millions of people play football
every year yeah if it was like 90
getting CT oh [__] right I shouldn't be
playing football I think I think uh I
think it's real
um but I also think that as a
combination of what somebody else us
already have going on right depression
no anxiety all the other [__] and if
they don't have the the mental capacity
because they've had some injury to their
brain they can't control it right so I
think there's a combination of both I
don't believe because if this for
example right like Antonio Brown out
doing stupid [__] saying stupid stuff
yes and and instead of just calling this
guy [__] or what he is right or jerk
they blame it on CTE it did a lot of
that behavior did seem to happen after
he had that what about the guy having a
possible drug problem what if he's
oppressed from from not playing football
he's always had issues he's always he's
always been a diva he's always been like
this wild boy so people that's my thing
too it's like something he might just be
an [__] right and would say no it's
easy we don't like I would say we don't
know I do think though that he took such
a bad hit and his behavior we know that
like a brain injury like a concussion
can cause
um certain kinds of behaviors yeah and
so I'm saying before that hit yeah
complete nightmare yeah complete
nightmare all before them it's
personality that's what we're saying
like he's also it's like it's like even
like Aaron Hernandez right yeah he does
horrible [__] murders me
he was doing Aaron Hernandez was doing
[__] like that in high school and
college correct so you're telling me I'm
not saying that CT is not real I know
it's I know it's real 100 familiar but
you telling me you had CT in high school
and college already I mean how many
years of football do you have to play in
order to have that right I think that
somebody's personality and intentions
are already a certain way and if they're
a certain way that having CT doesn't
combat it I think the CTE made Aaron
Hernandez gay
well I'll take wasn't that his he had a
boy there was this talk about it yeah
yeah he was like bisexual yeah God bless
him I like him more now but people will
say that like you can blame it on CTE
yeah [__] guys but I played the whole
world since I was [__] 11. I thought
he had tits no but the thing is is uh
within Hernandez so would it commit
suicide then they check his brain like
some of the worst CT we've ever seen we
think it's the big reason why he's doing
all this like no no go back to even his
middle school this kid was a problem
from Dave from John we also don't know
correct me if I'm wrong we don't know
that much about even when you look at
the brain right it's all they know they
can only investigate it when you're when
you pass away there's no other way to
check yeah yeah and then you you don't
even know if even if you do have CT it
may not manifest itself as behavioral
issues it may be something that you do
you know what so it's funny when that
concussion movie came out they actually
wanted me to be a consultant hell no
they asked me and I said no immediately
for one when you do stuff like that it's
Hollywood right so you're gonna they're
gonna make it whatever the situation is
dramatic dramatic and everything else so
I said one no because two I was still
working with NFL and then three I don't
believe like if if you have one percent
of guys that have some problems right
and I do I know guys that got problems
me too yeah um and so that's how I know
it's real but if you're taking that one
percent and you're making it seem like
there's 50 of guys like that then I
don't want to be a part of that because
that's not true that's right it also
Hurts The Narrative it also then parents
don't want their kids to play like right
you haven't seen decline now because of
all that it's still going on it's not
good yeah
how about you with uh football does that
do you think about that with your son
because we've had football players who
are like well uh no not really but I did
talk to him about like the dangers of
certain things right like you're going
to get hit you're going to like I've
never had a concussion where I missed
any time like anything serious but I
have had big hits where you see those
little dots or little white slides a
little you know your bell run then by
the time you get back to another you're
fine so I was explaining to him that hey
you know and but my son is like me he
took offense
he was like thinking I was calling
himself I said no no I'm not you know
I'm not calling you soft I'm just
telling you that it's a violent game and
you don't have you're kind of crazy I
feel like you're the concussion Giver
like there are certain dudes that are
built a certain way muscles when your
gut muscles yeah I just I called it
charity right
charity because I was giving
up all it'd be Sean Merriman yeah you
know what I mean and so uh and I also
because that was my intentions was to go
in and cause like physical harm to
somebody right yes and I think a lot of
I think I think a lot of concussions
happen when you don't know that it's
coming like crack back blocks like I'm
glad they got rid of that like how it's
War dude I've seen him Rock people in on
in the field where you watch these old
army movies and the [__] a bomb just
explodes
right and so Heinz uh I used to see him
hit somebody and I'm running by the ball
and I just see a body blow up really the
wide receiver
really I was just saying
what a combo you know that yeah and and
and but not big thick yeah not big but
feisty yeah he was known for those
cracks yeah I like Pac-Man Jones that
guy was uh pack is one of my favorite
people in the world do we sign with the
same we signed with the same agent
coming out of college Gary with short
and uh me Gary me Pac-Man Darren Sproles
Travis Johnson we all signed living
together damn and so I used to hear and
I was wild already right like I did my
thing I was out like lights out and I
don't [__] blue Mohawk I was you know
doing [__] and I was like I came across
somebody who was like me but worse right
like yeah why so and I'm saying worse
than not a way but so much that he was
like he had pack used to have uh uh a
big uh what do you call those buses the
tour buses right with like his face and
[__] on the side like his own tour bus
with his own crew and I was like yo this
dude is wow I love like he's running it
hard still to this day package pack is
one of my favorite people in the world
because he's he's never changed how's he
doing he's he's great man he bought
didn't he box recently yeah he just he
just fought he looked that great yeah he
looked real but the one before he did
yeah the one before he looked pretty he
didn't train for this yeah how tall is
he five eleven yeah
when we first because he went six people
Tennessee I went 12. so when you get
drafted that way you get a line of
credit from the agents right so he got
like a million dollars a line of credit
I had like a half million dollars oh
yeah you get a lot of credit and so we
all living in La for the first time
never been to the West Coast and uh
Packwood
he went to bought a 10 000 mink right I
swear to God so he had he had iced out
he had Iced Out Pac-Man chain this for
this no don't buy a [__] mink no no
he bought a mink good luck and no no and
then not only that he takes the [__] and
cut the cut their sleeves off come on
with no shirt on the way in the club
okay I'll talk about one of them that's
the greatest thing I've ever heard in my
life one of my favorite people in the
world still to this day man so I love
Pat
gangster the best dude I'm gonna buy a
10 000 man can cut the [__] sleeves
off no shirt under it I'm surprised you
and him haven't done a thing like you
know the NBA has all the smoke yeah like
those about Matt Barnes you know and
Jackson those are my boys yeah I'm
surprised you and like pack don't do
something like that lasers out there
like Brandon Marshall but he's a little
different than yeah he's the energy
consistency he sounds like he's hard to
Rope Rope down cool pack yeah no no he's
great dude literally he um you know how
somebody like because they've been in so
much [__] you got this perceived like
thing of them yeah and he spent 15
minutes when he's like dude no he's not
like that yeah nothing like that at all
you know why I always love did you ever
get to know Randy Moss yeah that that
dude I loved because he just didn't give
a [__] he was quiet he was such a
country Yeah country boy but we we were
yeah I worked with Randy uh at Fox
before he went to ESPN so I was spending
a lot of time with him he's another one
like you said you know you sell you see
all the clips like growing up right uh
Straight Cash homie and all this other
[__] yeah and you like you want to say
with Randy Moss like it's [__] cool
and then he's again one of the one of
the best people he was sitting like this
and I wasn't there but he I was doing
the shoot that he was part of and uh guy
goes I wanted to meet him you know
because he's not he wasn't there like
that was damn yeah he's real bristly
though and I go why he goes I don't know
man I I uh the guy came up to him and he
goes hey can you sign my ball and and
Randy yeah Randy goes and he was sitting
just like that too he's like this he
goes he goes why do you want me to sign
your ball and he goes ah you know I just
want you to sound a little while he goes
so you can sell it on eBay right the guy
goes no and he looks at me he goes yeah
though
come on man he goes well you know goes
I'm not sat in your ball this is great
yeah like you know I mean he was a
prickly dude but he was [__] as good
who do you think is if you if you had
your choice of the of two receivers I'm
gonna give you your I always love asking
this like quarterback like pick your
dream team you know this is your best
shot I give you a quarterback I give you
two receivers I give you two linebackers
excluding yourself I know go so believe
it or not I think the the best
quarterback I played against was Peyton
Manning
Tom I mean in the grand scheme I would
believe that in the grand scheme of
things everybody will say Tom Brady can
he call his own place dude it was it was
it was Unreal yeah Peyton Manning will
line up and he would look at this left
this side this cornerback to that
cornerback and everybody in between just
[__] call out what y'all doing stunts
my back is so smart like he would that's
why they called in the general right he
was out there he called his own players
ran his own ship yes I'm taking I'm
taking Peyton
um you know linebacker I'm I'm taking
Ray really yeah over how about LT
outside LT
um you know d-tack on taking Aaron
Donald over anybody
um who's the stud on your head's team
though Savage uh Jamal Williams Oh Jamal
Jamal Williams I've seen him run down
the like with Hawk running backs down at
300 plus pounds 350 pounds people forget
how freaky dude Jamal used to come to
the gym with no warm-ups we had an eight
o'clock Jamal Williams we had an eight
o'clock workout type in D tackle and
Jamal Williams will walk in the gym no
warm-up no nothing and put four play
four or five over there 15 times [__]
and walk out and leave swear to God what
the [__] just he was next level level
yeah
yeah he does he just got inducted into
the charges Ring of Honor I think he
deserves to be in Hall of Fame 100 he
deserved to be a Hall of Fame exactly in
fact if it wasn't if it was I played
with him and Eagle remember the big
Russian Igor chansky we had to be him
and him a big big eagle or kept people
off of me so I was 101. I mean people
had to figure out where how to block me
because they were so good on the inside
that I didn't have any problems look at
his belly though at 350 and run your ass
down oh no the Chargers posted a clip
because he's in the ring of Fame they
post a clip of him Hawking this dude
down and he lights homeboy episode about
this running back it's bad so Insanity
Chargers Twitter Chad that look at the
size of him yeah yeah he's he's the next
level he was missing no meals either he
just shows up looking like a giant
[__] Garden so I I used to I used to
[__] with everybody on the team right
because I just I did yes so we had one
day and um
I ended up taking his uh shells not a
shoulder pads on certain days we take
the shoulder pads off we put on these
like light shells yeah and so I take and
I put Icy Hot right all in the shells I
mean I [__] right on the shoulders it's
hot it's it's hot outside like 85
degrees so he puts on his helmet puts on
the [__] he's at practice and I'm
walking by him I smell this icy hot and
his shoulders and [__] don't fight I
mean his chest back shoulders is on fire
and so he looked at me when he was on
fire and dude I took off I said you know
what I normally I normally mess with
everybody on the team but I said you get
he knew right away you get big mom
pissed off Sean's Twitter yeah he posted
it yeah you get you get uh you get big
mall man I got out of Dodge dude I was
like man the only reason why he didn't
[__] the reason why he didn't come back
and do anything to me is because he was
on fire he had to go he left practice
all his he took his his uh shells off
and his show he's black his shoulders
was bloodshot red
shot red damn bro
keep going
because and uh the the receiver on the
team
um Jackson he passed away right yeah
yeah because he's a he played University
of Northern Colorado yeah so he was he
was just that was uh that was him
um you just there he is Boom Jesus Jesus
he's a detox he's 350. why why is he all
the way down there boom oh God oh God
dude you're running straight and you get
turned that way isn't that crazy uh for
a detox you down dipped his head for a
second yeah he was insane
Jackson get murdered no he uh well
suicide yeah suicide and what's crazy
about that is is that they didn't say
nobody really knows right he he from
what I how old was he from what I hear
he's my favorite
Vincent Jackson yeah hey so I don't know
the details but I would talk to a couple
times he went to Tampa Bay that's when
he finished his career so I would talk
to him a couple times I'll reach out to
him every uh every every birthday I
think his birthday is in April something
so I've reached out to him and I used to
call him sweetie pie right one day he uh
he cracked black he cracked back blocked
me in practice lit me up right doing
regular day in practice and he sat me
down I got up and I was so pissed off to
because you know the team's like ooh
yeah and I was like okay all that man
you soft you sweet I'ma start calling
you sweetie pie so I called him sweetie
pie for his whole time that's what he
thought and so every birthday I would uh
I would reach out to him and text him or
whatever I said happy birthday sweetie
pie right yeah
and he would respond back all the time
and like the last time he didn't respond
yeah and then that's when I found out
about it isn't that terrible yeah he was
drinking a lot of Jackson had damage to
his heart liver kidneys that was
consistent with chronic alcohol problems
yeah he had a problem news comes days
after his family said Jackson was
diagnosed by brain researchers as having
stage two CT yeah see having as long as
careers he had you know how long did you
play Sean uh eight eight years so so
um
he was six five uh probably two 22 30
around a four four in the 40. the
University of Northern Colorado pretty
tough make the NFL from there freak for
Colorado boys yeah we love them he was
such a [__] freak but then it's tough
right so stage two CT that gets the news
yeah playing as long as he did like is
it CT that caused this or was it the
alcohol you know what I'm saying we go
back to what we say it right it's a it's
a combination of other things you may
have going on that CT is it doesn't help
if you do have it correct but you have
all the other [__] but alcoholism it's
like dying from code we find out you had
three underlying health conditions right
yeah diabetes you're obese like covet
did like whatever was a problem for sure
yeah it didn't help let's put it that
way oh that's tragic Vincent Jackson I'm
gonna go pee out of my huge dick I'll be
right back let's take a break so tell us
tell us about your uh lights out extreme
Fighting yeah first of all you know this
before you dip your toe into this fight
game I mean it's a tough business right
like so many people come in they get out
they learn that's harder than you think
but you just want to start your own
league and yeah so you know so what
happened was I was uh yeah I've been
around the [__] for like 17 years right
um and so just just being around the
sport in general I love that that side
of it but understanding like TV like
I've built TV shows and series for so
many different networks yeah and stuff
and and just putting together all this
stuff so I understood production
um and so I launched like side extreme
Fighting in 2019. we're on uh we just
had our our fight on fubo uh May 6 and
we broke into football sports top five
most watched all time but you're right
dude like this this business is is
competitive it's a lot of it's a lot of
[__] out there and there's a lot of a
lot of Egos and [__] man like it's it's
kind of it's kind of weird for me
because
um like nothing against Bellator and
Scott Coker because I work with them for
for a time I think love Scott Scott's
the best and then the people over the
Bellator is the best but when I started
seeing Bellator and pfl all these people
trying to go against UFC and fight like
I don't understand that right I don't
get that part of it like the UFC is a
UFC they are who they are right
um every our last four fights we had we
had at least one if not two guys all
leading go to the UFC so we're fine
we're okay with that yeah yeah that's a
good thing it's a good thing yeah and so
for us we're climbing you know we just
broke into all these these viewership
records and all that but one thing we
are trying not to be is the UFC we don't
care that's the key you know it's the
guys look at them like competition it's
like no they're good that's like uh the
rock who started his uh football NFL's
not your competition no you don't want
to try to compete with that you're not
going to win we have we have so much um
Tech and Innovation and stuff coming
um betting we're about to you know have
a we're going to make a big announcement
where we're rolling out the stage that
people can bet on us and stuff like that
throughout you know we got a whole
committee you got to go through it so
it's a lot but what we're not trying to
be as a UFC so when I see pfl in Don
Davis and Peter the Great guy I like
them too I think they're really good but
they spend a lot of money a lot of it
all the money and so we we're just we're
not built like that like we want to be
an incubator for AI Tech right all this
new [__] is coming and every like three
to six months we're going to be
introducing new tech we're incubated for
these other tech companies is coming the
fights are going to be the fights right
and we normally have anywhere between 12
and 16 fights on any in a given month
all right our next one is July 22nd will
be in San Diego my first time actually
going back to San Diego since I played
this year ago like having something
there so it's a big deal for us
um but what we're not trying to be as a
UFC man and I think that it just makes
everybody look weak when you're trying
to compare I agree like Scott man is a
is a [__] he's a legend man like in
this business
so when I see him saying hey I think the
the Bellator should fight the UFC like
why why you know you're like well he
might have the cash for it and the
market share for it right not anymore no
they're selling two pfl they are yeah or
in the process of doing it yeah the
rumor is did Bellator start slipping in
the ratings or what was going on well
the problem so when I was working with
Belgium I think bellator's biggest
problem was is they wasn't innovative
the the days of just trying to have
great fights and be big is over because
UFC got that market you're not going to
do this these are Coca-Cola like there's
a ton of soda out there but there's only
one coconut yeah so if you're trying to
compete with Coca-Cola no that's done
that's right if you're just gonna do the
same Coke you know the same soda but
different packaging and not as tasty you
don't have the same Fighters but one
Championship is is a player like in
terms of worldwide globally they're
bigger worldwide but then also one
Championship has the bankroll to compete
with it and the other key to any Lee and
you know this it's also the roster like
like one Championship has depth right
these other leaves don't have debt also
one Championship has stars massive stars
yes worldwide Mass oh yeah yeah globally
globally outside of the USC nobody even
comes close to one Championship is when
it comes to name recognition what
massive because you got even some of
their female Fighters yes bro massive
the pop see that's the problem but the
pop is like when I went to the one
championship fight in Denver they flew
me out there to attended bro I was like
I bet the crowds just they want to see
fights she walked out it was the biggest
I was like she she they know what's
going that Mikey who we had on here oh
yeah insane she's so she's so
entertaining that's right she's super
entertained and she dances she got a
great like yeah no I know like think
about her she's you know she can throw
down she can go too oh bro but I think
that one thing that one Championship has
done differently is went after a
different market and they grew their
market then they got big now they're
coming here yeah see that's the that's
so if you're going to do it I think
bellator's biggest problem was they were
trying to get all former UFC guys that's
going to fight a couple fights and be
done that's what was going right you pay
them big money for one or two fighters
you got this big boom you go away
there's no longer there's no longevity
you want to grow and build your stars
and like for us we like what we're going
to announce with fan engagement Tech and
stuff in the next couple months it's
going to turn a lot of people's heads to
the industry that don't mean we're
trying to compete with the UFC because
we don't care right we're not trying to
go out and raise 200 strong thing right
that's different like pfl raise almost
300 million dollars for what you know
like I think that they have something
good already that they grew at a organic
level then they'll be fine for the long
term
I don't know if they're gonna be fine
for the long term because of with the
money they're paying the deal they did
with Francis I feel like the pressure's
all on pfl now I'm like man I don't see
how you get your return Don Davis one
thing he he's great at doing raising
money and doing like he's great at that
Peter's great and then George Greenberg
when they're on their production shot
who I've known for a very long time
they're great they got some great people
there I just don't understand the
long-term philosophy and what they're
trying to build what is your your exit
look like when you raise 300 plus a
million dollars
who's on ESPN right so they and they
signed Jake Paul Jake Paul right he
might fight in there and then decide
Francis outside that yeah I felt sorry
for my ignorance it's not one
Championship no very completely two
different leagues one's a professional
Fight League which is a tournament style
so they have tournaments okay the winner
gets a million dollars so you have to
get enough points to enter the
tournament it's like a playoff system
it's a different yeah yeah it's like a
playoff system which all that stuff is
cool and different which is different
which is cool and if you're going to
compete with the UFC which nobody will
but if you are going to compete with
them you have to be creative Innovative
and different there's no other way and
so what we wanted to start doing like
when I came in like we'll have a fight
every four to six weeks right for the
from this until the point on our
viewership has grown with football we're
that we we we're in the top five behind
watch behind the international soccer
behind all the other programs they have
there so if you're going to grow
organically you're going to do that and
then start adding different verticals to
make it cool and fun for people to get
involved yep you're not going to and
that's one thing that I don't understand
what pfl is great is the people they
have working there is like what is your
end game because you know who the
monster is in this in this business yeah
yeah it's weird too because they're on
the same platform they're both on ESPN
yeah it's a weird who who knows I'm sure
they have a game plan but I you know I
don't see it and they also don't have
stars they don't have songs like I Kyla
Harrison was their biggest star lost
it's tough man I went I went to their to
their fight I was there uh Don and those
guys and Ray they invited me when they
had to fight in Vegas
um at the not the hard work but the
Virgin the Virgin hotel and I went there
the production is great everything looks
great the problem is is that when you're
spending the money in the level of of
the UFC and you're not getting into UFC
numbers what is your end game with that
and I don't understand that so for us
we're not even attempting to compete
with anybody we want to because a lot of
people is at the company now are former
Tech guys that I'm with former um people
are in like finance and stuff so we're
doing some really cool [__] and then we
just want to keep growing organically we
don't care about like people that's what
I do like some of these offers that I
get honestly to for people to come in
and sell Equity you know like I own 100
of the company we have in-house
production we have in-house operations
everything is done in-house I have shows
coming um that I'm doing some stuff with
trailers I don't know if you heard of
children out there studios in Atlanta so
I got we're doing creative stuff content
Partnerships and keep growing with fubo
football is a sleeper like people like
people sleep on football because
football is a tech platform and people
don't really understand like what that
what comes you're gonna be on Brinks TV
would y'all break it yeah yeah so we so
I me and John talked to talk to him
yesterday yeah so me and Johnson we
talked once a week and so which Briggs
has one of the most interactive
platforms that's out there yeah but what
football had what football does for us
is allow us to try different things out
than nobody else can because they're a
tech platforms right so when I come up
with these ideas I'll call David gamler
Pam Duckworth or somebody at the network
saying I got this idea this Tech I want
to see if we can implement this and
they'll come back to me and say okay
this is what we can do right so every
fight we're starting to implement little
predictive stuff fantasy stuff yeah you
know all these all these different
things that's that for for me that's
what it's about because you can grow
your your your your net your fan base
with what you're doing but it's a lot of
Pride and it's a lot of dumb pride and
for sure you know dude I got a proposal
um probably six months ago from a
company trying to come and we're gonna
be bigger than the UFC and they sent me
all this I said dude get lost
I like get lost like you're not you're
just not if that's your attitude coming
in like what happened it's just not
gonna happen I mean in 30 years we'll
talk but yeah right
and so what's that for you what's the
end game with it well we really see it
we want to be an incubator right we want
we want you know verticals of a lot of
tech because what's happening now is and
I'll tell you like
Amazon spent a billion dollars for NFL
Thursday night football games for the
rights to it because they understand the
stuff that's included in live sports
there's so much data you can get in live
sports that's that's you can't get
anywhere else
fan engagement [__] matter of fact
Amazon that when they had that Thursday
night game against the Chargers and the
Chiefs
in those three days they had the most
sales they've ever had in Amazon history
they have 17 million people watching
damn yes so but see that's the power of
it so what they're basically telling you
is and then commercial the commercials
and so what else I I bring in so I did a
deal with football the partnership I
bring in all of our sponsorship I do all
of our venue deals with casinos
everything comes from me I do all of it
and I have a great team and stuff like
that but I have I've been around the
ship for 17 years so I navigated a
little bit different than everybody else
so you can't necessarily get into this
industry saying that you're going to be
bigger than UFC literally I told a guy
to send me that proposal the [__] off I
said dude you're out of your mind yeah
yes that's the way to go your energy is
dissipated there yeah it doesn't make
sense that's cool man you got to assume
too remember UFC's not staying the same
this had their biggest I mean Combat
Sports history boxing MMA did the
biggest year ever the UFC's leveling up
too so if the Gap was this every year
it's going like this if you just signed
with the WWE Yes UFC is sort of like
also kind of becoming yeah what what UFC
is doing now they're separating them if
you look at the stuff that they're doing
now they're separating themselves more
now than they have in the past like I
think between 2013 and 2016 Bellator
actually had a real shot to overtake UFC
they had they really had a real but they
just stayed the same what UFC is doing
now and now with with Endeavor like Mark
Shapiro and and already and all those
guys Emmanuel is doing this [__] over
Endeavor nobody will never come close to
him because now they're they're Crossing
two Fields people don't understand
four billion dollars people like oh my
God
21 billion though
well combine now combined combine
because now they combined with no I'm
saying when they bought I know I'm
saying now yeah estimated so UFC alone's
worth 12 billion what 12.6 billion
you're getting 11 point something
billion is uh WWE or 10 billion they're
worth more than WWE now and it's a hats
off to Dana that whole team 100 they're
separating themselves so much and to
make it to make it even crazier now
people understand how big the WWE is the
WWE on YouTube I think has a bigger
following in all the sports team
combined what
and so what's happening now is you
started to see Connor start to talk
about the WWE have uh Heyman Paul Heyman
is coming and talking there's about
there's there's about some stuff about
to happen with the UFC the crossover the
crossover that's going to separate them
so much that nobody can even think about
being close to that argument their Sean
is I don't know if that's good for the
sport of MMA when you start blaring
those lines where you know you got
because MMA is tough like the fan base
yeah it's tough but then also it's like
you're blurring the lines where the
Casual fans like hold up Undertaker why
is he at the UFC like right he's a real
fighter is Connor's fight real like is
this real so you're blurring the lines a
little bit well I think I think with the
story lines the build up and The
Branding is what they're going to put on
10 right because they've always been
good at these but that's what with the
contender series and all this stuff
they've been very telling the story
telling the story best they've been the
best at doing that's why they separate
themselves from everybody else but
what's about to happen now and I know a
lot of the WWE guys and I know they're
they're all talking the writers the this
yeah the build up is about to happen
with it with the UFC and WWE and I'm not
it they're about to go I mean the UFC I
think will probably end up being a 30 to
40 billion dollar company damn
at some point 12 billion but I got to
start fighting bro or investing you're
investing yeah yeah
five days ago you got some great events
for us Jen sure so but next event for
you is July uh 22 July 22nd in San Diego
yeah and you got to do a lot of it on uh
native land like reservations yeah
casinos yeah what's that pennant you're
wearing I like that what's this one this
is uh oh this necklace the lights out oh
the lights out yeah logos yeah this this
one says [__] off it's my daily reminder
yeah
you know I like about Sean he's that big
and he's got he's he's like got the
energy of a smaller Napoleon he's got
that in Napoleon complex like he's a
giant but just as intense as a little
dude who who never made the team I
[__] love that we've still got that
hunk that's be it that's me that's me
too because you know what I wasn't
always big too so you hadn't like been
Scrappy and [__] no you get some sizes
like oh [__] yeah but that's a big thing
like that's like you you still work like
you're broke you're just yeah yeah I
love it what's Vernon Davis up there
because he was doing some commentating
right yeah movies really foreign is a
great actor he got one that just came
out with like Morgan Freeman and [__]
damn yeah he's a great actor damn
yeah guy has it all ah man uh did you
guys watch the fight with uh Floyd
Mayweather and John got here I watched I
don't get why Floyd's doing this he has
to have some exhibition fights so money
so it doesn't count on his records I
guess money but I heard nobody's like he
did one I think in England didn't want
to bite and the stands are empty there
has to be a reason why he's doing it
because financially I think he uh back
to your point of the ego because I think
you can't give up the the chase the
juice of being in the Limelight and
these are easy fights for him well this
is well for one it was on the Zeus
Network Zeus is you know you can say
what you want about like the kind of
content that's on there I don't know
what's on there but ratchet [__] I mean
it sounds like it sounds like it's for
me yeah I like that yeah I mean I watch
it too I watch all I won't be I won't go
there but I'll watch it you know and so
but there Zeus is great Zeus is a and so
I think that Floyd
um I think he has some part either
ownership business or it's business and
so but but think about this when people
say that time like when you're a doctor
or your lawyer you can practice for 50
years right you can always make money
Floyd is making between five and ten
thousand ten million dollars for these
exhibitions and so when people say that
like oh he's doing it because he's broke
and I'm like no it's very humidity he
fought a couple rounds and if he made
five million dollars in in six minutes
and he doesn't get hit he's fighting
Gotti and which is a complete [__] show
that that whole thing was insane the
halftime show listen to her so it's real
good to know B before you read that to
give you context so he fought John
Gotti's nephew so you know it's a rough
family right so then yeah so they they
get in the fight the ref stops fight
because talking [__] to each other and
John gotta get I mean uh the Gotti kid
keeps grabbing like the rest like this
is warmed them so they break the fight
up like they call it a fight Gotti tries
to fight Floyd after the Bell just
throwing punches I saw that so the
squads come in Floyd's teams 20 20th
Floyd's guys jump down it spills out
outside of the the ring yeah goes on the
back Floyd's team tries messing up
Gotti's team guy's team was giving them
all they could handle it's you know the
Gotti's you know Punk that's right but
then uh but then the the one of Gotti's
team I think it's uh the aunt of him or
the mom but this is not me this is very
racist your daughter was ran through by
an animal with 12 different baby mamas
you little your little circus animal she
meant you you're all a pack of zoo
animals that's not racist at all I swear
on my kids I'm coming for your daughter
it may be two years three years from now
but I'm coming I think I think it was CT
which would be [__] yeah so but that by
the way that's the sister I think of uh
is is Floyd's guys what did Floyd's
daughter do and how old is Floyd's
daughter she's young she's very well she
got it she's pregnant and she's not
she's old enough to you know where she's
like enter there it's not like she's
like eight she's good she has a key able
to wrap her yeah it has a bunch of kids
yeah
21 21 so that's very young yeah but not
young enough we can't yeah
yeah she had a baby slept with this
rapper that's why she's saying that got
it which you know it look and I she went
on private after that all right old
school Mafia stuff but nobody's in the
market but you've got a family anymore
did you see this fight
he's racist about it I agree what are
you doing hold on hold on this is going
to be surprising you ready you got your
seatbelt on yeah they Gotti's they're
racist yeah
uh do you think the n-word has ever used
in that household I can promise you in
2013 though since well yeah back in the
day 1800 yeah the Italians yeah the
Italians in that part of uh
2023. yes papa but that some some
traditions die hard yeah especially when
there's well in this in this climate
the goddess used to be obviously very
very powerful right and very very feared
by everybody yeah
now in Nightmare when you do that [__]
doesn't matter who you are you gotta
you're gonna have a problem with your
hands because now you got you got random
people yeah well see the thing is back
in the day when it was in social media
you're talking like this you may be
walking on the streets of New York in a
random black person might knock your ass
out because they seen what you said
randomly yeah and so it's a different
time where hey they're not worried about
the goddess anymore no that's that
doesn't nobody cares no and so she has
to she gotta she got to go missing for a
little bit yeah stay behind closed doors
because you might want to lay low for
you might you gotta you gotta chill
because that type of [__] is walking in
the street nowadays with how crazy
people are in New York in New York it's
just it's just not it's just also
unnecessary that kind of language that's
that's some [__] up also you think
Floyd's worried about it this is in the
early 90s maybe it's this isn't good
Fellas now I talked to Sam Sammy the
bull recently about that I was talking
to him I said you guys could never do
anything he was he goes you couldn't do
it he goes I I'd be trying to make a hit
and 12 grandmothers without their phones
I just said that he goes you couldn't
get away with a thing you're on camera
all the time you're not doing [__]
um but uh how did that fight go did
anybody see it it was over in a round or
two right yeah he just kept wrestling
well he just I think it got to the point
where it's just an altercation it wasn't
fighting right talking [__] to each
other there's a weird like show with a
blue face where his name is yeah
it was it was a it was it was more
fights outside of the fight sure than it
was in Illinois
the production why did he do it what is
this well like you said he probably has
ownership in that dude
fighter yeah we live in that we live in
a time now where
um the crazy [__] gets views right yeah
that when that happened it was on every
social media site in the world yeah like
look at it right now everybody from
complex to ESPN I believe him it was
everyone viral yeah yeah wrong reasons
for the wrong reasons but is there such
a thing as wrong reasons really
you know so like nowadays like you know
controversy yeah Zion Williams might say
you went by for the wrong reasons right
well yeah
yo you're paying 170 000 a month in rent
that's a young man
I've been doing stuff like bro
I'm just more disappointed in did he
continue to text her after she already
put him on black she can't post it and
he kept why would you he's like please
take those down no once it's posted it's
out that's it uh that continues like
please
at that point is a voice note yeah I
ain't putting nothing else to write
because I already know you put me on
black that's like Tiger Woods like okay
first of all don't use your name uh
it's like tiger this is just gonna get
just gonna make it to you and then
Zion's PR team was like we're gonna do
something here and there's a picture of
Zion like oh you know Charities help
these kids out you're like hey no no no
that's not enough no no no hey don't do
that now you know what I would do that
do it when I posted if I was on for real
quick let's watch this I go I this is me
my picture
like
how old is he was he 21.
all girls 21 300 million dollar rookie
contract Nike deal my bad my bad if
anybody's ever seen what pro athletes
deal with like like you know you were
yeah it's it's not women are not hard to
come by you could make that argument
right when you see like people who are
known to be athletes the the it's so out
of control like I've been I've been in
Vegas where Derek Jeter was just sitting
down uh at the club and I've never seen
I mean I've known as Hollywood a long
time
in my life yeah but you gotta you gotta
understand too
um because of the the times has changed
was with a lot of this [__] right it's
not it's always happened sure but like
now there was no such thing as viral
when I played you know I mean like what
no virus this would be a story it was
not a story about like Jordan no stores
right he would be a different I think
that we would view him differently if
there was social media yeah
but for Zion yeah don't know anything
desire can do to fix the situation is
drop 30 pounds and average 30 on the
court hunt and stay healthy that's it
that's all we give a [__] about that's
it that's it hey
he was a young man he's been getting a
little crazy you know they're all
getting credit who gives a [__] I agree
just play basketball he changed the new
if he has the MVP season nobody gives it
this is real life so can you pull out
please you're 21. if we pull out would
it be crazy like it just has one baby
she's just pregnant now yeah but give it
time it's like hey [__]
anyway
you're a hater I'm an old man though I'm
an old man have you heard the rumors
about kalis and Bill Murray I love this
it's the greatest thing is
no it's real you know so it's a rumor
but someone actually posted or made a
comment on her Instagram I think and
that she didn't respond in a way that
was like convincing she says I don't
want to talk about them but Bill Murray
was like having a fun time go back oh
dude she's gorgeous but I mean she has
like three kids I think too
oh one by Nas yeah yeah they were
together oh damn yeah
to the table I'm not buying it why not
Bill Murray you're Bryan County a 30
year old Bill Murray 77.
look at Al Pacino you defending Alvin I
got skeptical hippo not me but she's not
denying it though so this is a comment
you're saying some women like old men
this is what I don't understand is like
how how it got to be a story right like
if nobody's seen them they get somebody
to see them you know what it is I don't
expect a black
female rapper to be into an old white
man
but that you know what I'm saying like
you you see the the reverse like it was
less racist are you a John Gotti yeah I
think he's like it's very alarming to
see an older white man with a black
is this did you're just gonna let this
go Sean John I'm just saying no I'm
saying you know he's like the thing is
a little bit of undertone yeah I did bro
now I think about it Brian's like it's
very alarming you see a black rat it's
just you know you you hit like when you
think not around a beautiful curvy black
singer who's 42 you go you would date uh
I don't know somebody else not a not
Bill Murray who I think he's probably a
great time that's that's so fun I think
that's the key if it feels just like an
older white guy wouldn't be a story but
it's [__] Bill Murray right that's
what I'm saying he's right such a good
time yeah and again she's 40. she's 43.
she's a full-grown woman she's probably
done [__] around with all the [__]
boys some [__] she's done with the
rappers we're still calling [__] I
hope it's true that'd be awesome I'm
still saying I don't think she's banging
billboard 72. no wrong in my book Bill
Murray the main thing is I just don't
see Bill Murray banging anybody why not
dude I don't know he seems like an old
guy you were cool with Al Pacino last
week she's a little bit different why
he's close to the ground bro he's five
foot six and he's Al Pacino even he's
80. can you imagine that how old is he
83 with a kid Al Pacino and if you've
seen his [__] girl she's 29 that's
out of control she's way hotter than Al
Pacino's girl
good looking woman she's got a great
body too okay because he's white okay I
see oh that's fine what do you mean
white he's Italian he's selling his girl
he's not that she's not she's all right
you know what Brian just tell us how you
really feel man yeah seriously she's
Arabic I love that he's like I don't
believe it man there's no way the black
rappers
I I mean okay
listen listen I'm just saying she looks
like she date Nas not Bill Murray that's
all it's uh Bill Murray doesn't seem
like her type but there are there are no
more though there are women that like
older men and famous
and talented super talented you're right
you're right stand correct Brian's races
that's fine
uh no
you got girl you got a girl well okay
never no this lights out yeah right well
one of these days I'm not against it
it's just that it's just too much [__]
going like it's the the rate of divorces
and all this stuff I'm impressed though
because you I'm sure you had a lot of
like I'm not sure from various
flow for a couple years so if I was
going to settle down and then yeah you
know Buffalo is a town did you get
attached to the town honestly I was
kicking a scream and going there yeah
and then you loved it and I loved it
yeah that's why it's hard for them to
get free agents for a long time because
it's you know but they say once you're
there and you see the community so buddy
Nicks who's a the he was an assistant
general manager into charges he was
actually the one who drafted me with the
charges and he was he was a GM and um in
Buffalo he called me when when I was
getting waived or released and traded
whatever he said Sean we're bringing you
out here like buddy I love you to death
but I'm not coming
I said I'm not coming I said you guys
are on seven you know I'll come and see
you after the season but I want to go to
a team that I can play so I'm not coming
there he said Sean I mean I hear you
love you to death I'm putting in your
contract in NFL I don't give a [__] what
you do I'm not coming wow and they he
called me back 20 minutes later with the
owner Ralph Wilson on the phone I said I
said Mr Wilson
buddy I love you guys I'm not [__]
coming it's called a [__] up thing so it
was no no TV games they're on seven not
going to the playoffs so that's what he
did he said uh he said look Sean I I
you'll be a great leader on the team
great leader in the locker room we want
you here I said I don't give a [__] I
don't give a [__] I'm not coming he said
well you know comments we're gonna find
you fifteen thousand dollars a day I
said what time you sending the jet and
that was it yeah they sent me the plane
like three days later then you don't
regret it you liked it but it was it was
the best thing that happened for me in
my career because in San Diego it was
great playing but we won a lot of games
we had star swords you had a reason to
come to the game yeah to have that
genuine kind of love it was in Buffalo
everybody like everybody to play sports
news
I mean they donate like that that month
they raised money for you know teams
that have nothing to do with them it's
the best fan base in the world what is
that what is the weird question what's
the code
the 07 AFC Championship game in New
England it was like 11 degrees
are you one of those guys I love more
sleeves you never wore sleeves never
wore sleeves but it was a one game is
that a mental thing for the other team
well that and plus I was just a psycho
too right but it was I've never had this
before so we had to you got the heaters
on the side I got the big fan blowing
and [__] right and we're coming off and
between you know offense on the field
defense off and so I come in front of
the fan and our kicker Nick cating was
hogging up and hogging up the fan and
I'm freezing cold you can't feel your
fingers your fingers hit the helmet is
the worst feeling in the world your
fingers hit the helmet like it's
bleeding how about your feet toes and
all that [__] right so cold right so
he's hogging up the damn heater and I
literally picked him up and threw his
ass out the way I said dude it's
freezing out here yeah I like Nate I
love you dude but yeah he's good get
your ass out to warm up yeah it was the
first it was the first time where I got
to the end of the game I was like this I
don't care win or lose I don't want to
get [__] off yeah that was the first
time ever that was I was in pain because
somebody just stepped on my hands from
the pile and my hands I just wanted to
cut my hand off yeah well it's not a
hard sell anymore they're balling now
yeah because with Josh Allen New Stadium
Club yeah people yeah new stadium yeah I
would have put I would have had heater
heating pads all over my body
because you only wear a couple you could
wear a couple layers right like no I
don't know
you're a [__] Maniac I don't know
what else you got chance all right here
Georgie
hi it's a weird question but when I see
it more I think this is a little
loophole Nick Cannon found in the system
brilliant businessman don't have to pay
child support after 10 kids apparently I
can't that's the loophole I don't know
if that's true oh no sound well what
happens I think the text Cromartie I
think that I think the thing is is uh
it's a set amount right like no kid can
get more than another kid you know in
certain stages so there's a there's a
cap there's a cap even if you're a
billion in so certain States there's a
cap like I think Texas has a cab like a
couple other uh States what's the cap
that's like 2 500 or 3 000 something
crazy per kid a month yeah
exact number but it's pretty low
assistant
yeah what's with Nick Cannon and all
these kids he just wants to spread his
seed man well he has a lupus right is it
lupus he does he has yes I think that
he's passing that Gene along I think
that um a lot more people are not
talking about that like he has a he has
a timetable on how long he's going to
live He's already they've already
they've already given him a timetable I
think it's his kidneys his kidneys are
something he has a he has a something
you know talented one of the most and
from San Diego yeah that's right San
Diego San Diego and uh so he people
don't people are not they're talking
more about the kids if they're not
talking about like his reasoning for
going through like he they gave him a
time limit this is no joke bro yeah
uh after 10 kids you don't have to pay
child support
that's not true so he's he's kind of
trying to spread his seed so he can live
on but look at that this is absolutely
not true there's no cap on child support
based on the number of children so to
the extent that Nick's Nick Cannon can
have babies he owes child support for
those babies California
well California is the worst thing yeah
you don't want to get divorced here but
uh
how do you father 10 kids from 10
different families that's that's what I
have a problem with it's like how do you
have time for all this all the time and
and he's you know busy dude he's in him
he's all over the place to me I don't
respect that
it depends yeah I don't know if you can
manage it I don't know how he can but
he's just he just wants to come inside
them which is like if you're a bachelor
don't come inside well I mean there's
more well I think that sounds like he's
trying to like Phillip Phillip Rivers he
has Phil has a lot of kids does he he
has like nine like nine yeah
he's a religious thing though right yeah
so he's been with the same person yeah
she's great he's a beast of a dad he's
known for being he's like a big it's so
he's like a big kid himself I bet you
know he's like a big himself and so
people always make nine yeah nine oh
that's amazing Seven Girls two boys
from three to twenty that's hilarious
he's a beast
he's got to be what 40 now yeah he's a
couple 41 three or four years 41 yeah 41
right yeah so but he's a great dad dude
he's still he coaches all his kids and
like he's oh man he's he's next level
amazing good for him
Gunner Rivers great name yeah Connor
Haley
yeah
so here's the before we so the headline
for those listeners says dead woman
wakes and coughing at her own funeral
you know this used to be such a problem
back in the day George Washington had a
thing where uh if he was dead they had
to leave the body for a week before they
put him in the ground because back in
the day it used to be a problem where
they thought people were dead they're
bearing them and they they would open
the casket and see fingernails because
people would wake up like back in there
was a real like it was a real problem so
the people were traumatized so they even
had a thing where people would die back
in the day that they would have tubes in
the coffin and go up to the ground so
you could hear just in case just in case
oh my God that's how big of a problem
was back in the day well I know this
could not tell you
that's some pretty crazy [__] to know I
have no idea that'd be real bad to wake
up from a coma and be like huh I'll be
the worst turn on the lights oh my God
so this dead one wakes in a coffin our
own funeral is it Ecuador yeah so the
medical examiner declared her dead four
hours prior I don't know why they put in
her in a coffin four hours after but
either way so they declared her dead and
then she started knocking on the on the
coffin at the at like the visual yeah
during the ceremony whatever
and she's still alive right now holy
[__] she's still kicking yeah because I
figured she'd wake up knock and then die
again nope I'm fine you asked and she's
still being placed in the same hospital
that declared dead which is kind of you
think I would ever go back there I know
exactly it says my mother is on oxygen
her heart is stable now the doctor
squeeze her hand she reacted they told
me it's a good sign because it means
she's reacting little by little not only
I thought my mother's house improves I
want to lie about Jesus Christ mom's
like remember when you buried me you son
of a [__] yeah yeah that's kind of
crazy yeah could there be a worse death
being stuck on the ground yeah yeah I I
guess you run out like buried yeah
horrific well that's why they had those
twos back in the day like George
Washington days so you could still get
it here just in case did you see that
guy who got eaten by that yeah I saw
that that's what you know what so I got
Russian Feller yes I am terrified of the
ocean that's one thing I won't do I got
plenty of friends to Surf and [__] like
that like I I won't go this guy's a seal
this dude's like I love it yeah because
you know it's way out there this is my
thing I think sharks are the least of
our worries out there I think there's so
much we don't know [__] about it yeah
they say we know more about space than
the ocean I'm like why is that dude look
at that go back for a second have you
seen the video
there's a straight up video of someone's
filming like oh my God he's yelling and
the target sharks eats him alive and he
starts in the blood and then and yeah I
see the blood like a whole Jaws movie
and then they these the guys out there
this is in Egypt by the way this is
Egypt it's right outside of Egypt
look at him just getting annihilated by
the tiger I thought we saw this a long
time ago though no this is this happened
like a few days ago chin and it was
nothing I could do nah what are you
gonna do we definitely can't show this
on then they get on a boat and they
catch the shark and beat his ass how are
you gonna kill the shark shark doing
shark [__] this is his father watched
the horse
he had been better if he was a great
white because the tiger sharks don't
give up
see somebody in the ocean will only know
that because I wouldn't know that you
want a great white's gonna bite leave
the tiger sharks that that shark was
eating it right yeah oh no it's right
just look at that he just disappeared
now the boat comes he's gone it's
arterial bleeding you see all that blood
[__] dude that's terrific dude it was it
was one time that I almost went so uh so
junior junior say out he would Surf and
uh wakeboard Oceanside
almost every day right all the time good
too and so um they him in like a group
almost finally convinced me to go and uh
the week before I was about to go there
was a doctor in Oceanside or somewhere
and they got eaten by a shark and almost
not even a mile a mile and a half from
where we were supposed to go check
please and I said that's it no no I'm
done yeah I would never get in the water
no not with great whites that bite you
in half no thanks you'd rather have a
great white than a tiger shark that
tiger sharks
usually bite you and let you go and
leave that thing was eating him that
thing ate him yeah my buddy who's a
scuba diver professional diver said you
hear about people disappearing all the
time you never know it's a shark but
that's what that's what goes on I'd say
no [__] dude you know yeah shark just
comes so at the uh my first Pro Bowl
when I went as a as a rookie and when it
was still back in Hawaii those were the
good days
yeah yeah dodgeball yeah it's weird and
so they ESPN was uh they were doing this
piece and they wanted me to get in a
cage
uh like a shark dabbing oh that's sick
so like a piece of the you know Pro Bowl
special you know I said look um no
you like like you got like find somebody
else or whatever so they offer like ten
fifteen thousand dollars in the payment
so it's like it's great money just we do
we need like uh two hours of your time
you only got to be down there ten
minutes I said you guys Now understand
what I'm saying I said no I'm not yeah
because I would be the one person that
will go and that's something what
happened with the court cage opens up
the cage opens up just out it would
happen to me right so he said um all
right well how about twenty thousand I
said you got you didn't hear me the
first time because it's still no I'm not
going right so they got all the way up
to like almost thirty thousand dollars
for me to shoot this um this episode for
ESPN on the shark diving and I said no
I'll pass and somebody else did it and I
said good for them because I would never
no I said I would never do I went to
South Africa and you dive with great
whites so we're gonna go on a great
white Dodge I was like I'll get in the
cage so I can say I did it so you get
out there water's beautiful and here's
what what's funny about animals the
cages are already there the boat pulls
up now the sharks have been trained when
they hear the boat they don't know
they're going to get trapped so all of a
sudden you just up there and they all
show up the problem was there were no
gray whites there were bronze Whalers
and lots of other sharks for a refund
well because the great whites the woman
said to me quietly she goes well there
were two brother orcas that came into
them oh scared them away and we found
four 20-foot great whites with only
their liver bitten out of their body
it's a great way every every great white
that it was like we're out of here sorry
guys no show today you know you're a bad
[__] when all the great whites
are like the show has been postponed
hadn't seen a great wife for a year
because those two brothers yeah
gangsters came in their life but that's
what so knowing that what makes people
want to get in the water still I don't
know I agree with you now killer whales
are [__] boats up did you see that so
it was crazy it was some I saw it just
last week it was a guy that was like a
small boat and there's another guy on
the kayak yeah man on a kayak on a kayak
in the middle of the ocean and the damn
um uh well came up and swallowed them
and they got out he spit them out giant
whale you sperm whale or something well
well uh they these uh killer whales that
are attacking sailboats and stuff in
Yachts that's great they think the
female got injured and then her the her
pod just does what she says so did you
see what they did in Gibraltar they
finally got there at night as the boat
was sinking but those [__]
literally you can did you see the video
of them good for them see it yeah and it
tore a huge hole in the hole Yeah man
good for them
hmm
yeah no one can never get me in the
ocean that's just not gonna happen and I
can swim killer whales ain't something
to [__] with either I don't know why
people want to [__] with these things
are you at a Sea World you look at those
things like what are we doing here
what's the percentage that we've seen in
those like 90 well I mean we we haven't
seen 90 of it yeah but again they say we
know more about space than our own ocean
yeah because we can't get to the depths
so who knows what the [__] down there
yeah
[__] with the ocean oh my God I love the
ocean
I wasn't very good when I first moved to
LA I surfed all the time I remember
doing the countdown on me when I was
fighting somebody no gear or something
like that pro cop and I just came to L.A
like you surf right like can we feel me
surf I'm like hell yeah yeah I get out
there like oh you paddle board I'm like
no it's my board so I get out there but
I wasn't very good I kept falling and
they're trying to film it and they
couldn't get the footage and they get
they're out there for two hours and the
guy goes so um are you gonna like surf
or you just kind of like boogie board on
here oh my God I couldn't I couldn't get
up I kept falling kept falling and the
waves were really yeah I can do it uh
two hours so you you've never you've
never been in there and something hit
your leg or you're like no no if I think
about I'm like all right I'm the [__] at
her but I'll switch Brian's been with
you I swim deep man I go like how hot
like how far up way past the in the the
lifeguard but get back I love it and
he's dying I look like a seal he's not
going like this with his arms yeah I go
like this I'm like bro you are like
burning it and you look like a seal
you're just a giant scrumption the thing
is the juvenile great whites that are
out there eat fish when they get to be
about 12 feet they switch to marine
mammals they think great whites don't
eat human beings or when they bite them
they let go because they don't have
enough fat on them and so you don't have
the kind of fat content that the cl does
and I guess they need that for fuel so
it's almost like
the problem is is that when they take
when they taste a part of your body they
take an arm or a leg so it's not like
it's not like a little bite no it's not
like a little bite also all the experts
say that really what shark told you that
yeah that's right I'm calling [__]
because my target shark friend there
that Russian learned the wrong way he
was a snack that is look at the mouth on
that [__] too it's a tiger shark
like you're getting bit you're getting
pieces pulled out of your body [__] you
I tell my girl if I passed away in a car
accident whatever it is tell my kids I
got eaten by a great white I'll come up
with some cool she's getting bit right
here it'd be fun to lose your hip just
gonna take I'm gonna take a piece of
your ass in your head but that woman
she's swimming with uh on in Hawaii a
bull shark comes along goes I'm gonna
eat half your ass and just took one of
her jokes on you because it's fake shoot
just bit her ass right off well so I was
and there's another reason why I don't
get in because I actually seen some [__]
happen so when I was living in the off
season in Miami and my place is on the
22nd floor boy you were living daddy oh
yeah yeah San Diego Miami yeah I had
bought a place
21st Collins before the [__] was built
exactly where that is I've been in that
hotel fantastic yeah
is
well they've just opened up their Club
done a club wall at the same time oh
[__] I'm [__] right yeah
um it's literally literally and so Dodie
Austin's now we're going in and train uh
with Pete Bommarito who's in um uh [__]
he's is he all the Miami guys went down
there like CP and uh Fred Taylor all
these guys went down the train so I
would train with them during the
off-season I'm up there on the 22nd
floor so I can see down to see
everything
and so I seen about it was a guy that
was that was swimming out there laying
on his back and a tiger shark there was
about 45 to 50 feet away beelining right
to him and people were screaming at the
top of their lungs together and so the
guy it got about 10 to 15 feet away from
him and some something for whatever
reason he's just so lucky he turned he
probably was a clue he had no clue got
it bull sharks and tiger sharks will
cause more problems than a great white
it's all a disaster Nile crocodile sir
oh disaster it's all disaster what else
you got Jeff all right Georgie a fan
sent this video in of a snake breaking
through there I saw this I haven't seen
this is this different than that one in
like Jakarta or something watch them
swing off how about a CTE oh I just
what's different there's no watch how
bro
oh my God man he got [__] up that
snake's like Jesus
snake too he's getting so messed up for
sure it's poisonous
to talk to dude
this thing is like holy [__] I can't
fight right now I don't have I don't
have a lot of a lot of I don't have a
lot of fears in life but the sharks and
snakes in my top two snakes don't bother
me sharks scare the [__] out of the
state in the wild about well I see
snakes not so much anymore but all the
time I surround my bike I've been riding
my bike hoping they come out now because
I live you know right back here in the
mountains so I ride my bike all the time
and during the pandemic when nobody's on
the roads I would send Brian pictures
and videos I post all the time
rattlesnake because I saw rattlesnake
side of anaconda just I see all these
dope snakes and Rogan's like I need to
get you he wanted me to wear those shin
pads so it doesn't bite me on the legs
I'm like I'm not wearing those I'll take
my chances yeah those were dope then my
son he's really into reptiles and steak
so we have all these [__] fish tanks
my house like Jumanji so we're there and
the guy goes we got new snakes and I go
cool I don't want a snake my son goes
dad can I hold it I'm like Mama let me
talk to you snakes bite dude he's like
no it's not a big deal like all right
you guys like no this ain't done do
anything my son goes to hold it Waka
bites his [__] hand yep what kind of
thing was oh [__]
that was a little like uh ball snake
some [__] yeah but as a baby but
still bit the [__] out of his finger and
I'm like you still want a snake see I I
don't get in water because of the Sharks
not that I can't I love swimming and
then the snakes you can't see him I had
a uh when I lived in San Diego I lived
on a on a canyon I had two dogs and so
one night I heard my I heard my dog just
barking crazy and I got up in the middle
of the night and I went outside and
there was a mountain lion you could see
his eyes it was hover around the fence
don't scare me let me guess what you
have Connie Corso two pit bulls I had
two pit bulls now they were grown they
probably would have they would probably
hold on but the problem the problem is
the the end up jumping on the fence and
I chased the mountain lion out out the
back I seen a I seen a garden snake when
I was in the pool one time and I ran I
took off running yeah it's just
something about snakes that I can't did
you you like living in San Diego that is
the best place in the country that's
where I want to move man San Diego keep
telling me
don't don't tempt me you love that whole
I love it down there chin look kg wants
to go yeah I'd go where would you live
at San Diego I lived in um in Scripps
Ranch in Poway like a lot of the
baseball players live in Poway where I
lived at it's great too yeah and so I
had a place I had a place downtown in
case I like went out and I didn't want
to go all the way back so I had to play
downtown in uh downtown the Gaslamp okay
and I had so I bought into the uh
stingery I wonder if you're in a
nightclub and state back in the days it
was the biggest nightclub in San Diego
it's like a landmark it was there for 11
12 years and then we got bought out by a
hakkasan group after like 10 years but
it was it was the first like three level
rooftop big boy big boy in San Diego and
so I had a place right across the street
at the harbor I bought a place to Hard
Rock and I had my house
yeah man and so all pro yeah what are we
doing
was the landmark of San Diego it was
like if you came I don't care where in
the country you were and in fact during
that time I think the stingery might
have been the best club in the country
damn in my opinion you know okay what
are we doing
you're talking about a couple 12
steppers over here and you just keep
talking about
last time like this tell me more about
it
where's my Bible I would demand when I
walk in the club with my name if my
nicknames lights out we shut the lights
he and I are going Sean's here quick
after this we're going to church
what do you got is that it chin uh just
one more thing
um hold on Sean Mary Okay so
so Billy eilish you know she usually
covers up her body not anymore man she's
feeling empowered and I'm not mad at
least the sweater puppies boom Daddy
yeah anybody have a problem with that
she's a talented gal she can sing that's
a good way to put it yeah yeah
on her IG she's 21. let me see but she
usually yes typically hides her body but
uh she's showing her that's she usually
hides those sweater puppies
feeling empowered
different things there's that there's
this but see that's where she normally
yeah she usually dresses really baggy
like them people like you're changing
and she's like [__] off why just because
she's so curvy that's her again yeah
because you used to always hide it she
wanted to be known for her Talent not
her giant yeah I don't blame her yeah
but also release them right
have a voice but also release them heavy
yeah at least the Heavies that Schultz
says I just look at personality guys
yeah dude I don't see tits I just see
cat Talent yeah you know there she is
that's a lot of talent God bless her
America baby is that it that's it and
then so Sean's fight promotion yeah you
said July 22nd San Diego lights out
extreme Fighting uh July 22nd San Diego
we'll be live on football TV football
sports and you know the cool thing about
this one so we normally have about uh 12
Flags we got 16 lined up we're putting
more amateurs on the card
um that's cool because you know there's
like I said there's really good
promotions out there whatever but
there's so many amateurs that's trying
to Big Time get a shot there's a lot of
talent out there and what's cool about
it is is uh I worked it with football
that a lot of these amateur fights make
broadcast so that's a little different
with us we'll have a four hour live
event and by the way like we talk about
the business being tough I mean it
produced four hours of live content when
you got TV trucks I like trucks all this
[__] going on more commentators yeah I
mean they're great man we got we got
some great stuff Pablo and bulletproof
too they're really good but uh yeah big
big fight first time coming to San Diego
uh July 26th I'm there if I'm in town
yeah no you got this one this one's
going to be this one this won't be our
biggest one and also we got like three
guys this card that took one more fight
before they signed to UFC they already
got I've seen the contracts already
that's cool and so you know I'm almost
thinking like I want to drive these guys
to the facility because I live in Vegas
yeah uh and dropped them off that'd be
cool you know like film it yeah yeah I
think it's I think it's fun set it free
I love you know giving these guys a shot
man we have a lot of these up and coming
guys so July 22nd San Diego live on
football TV I need a reason to get to
San Diego again I love it down there
I'll be in there Mr man you're the best
bro appreciate it bro thank you really
funny thank you really good
I'll be in fact I'll be in in Denver
then I'm
I'm in Springfield Missouri so uh it's a
good room though well you know Missouri
is a lot you know stop I was going to
say guys
but if you're in if you're in San Diego
area you go see that fight because the
people in Springfield look just like the
ones in San Diego that's right ladies
and gentlemen speaking of Pale
look at those pictures all right love
you guys we're out